[Applause]
bona fide badass man oh you got to keep
that badass you're really is does she
does I need it for like evidence
evidence office you can take a hit like
a champ man seriously take that what are
there any ladies we'd like to show this
super bad the 2007 comedy co-written by
Seth Rogen Rogen's laid-back manners
managed to deliver some hilarious
moments in film over the past 10 years
lately he's also been using humor to
benefit an important cause jamie wax is
here with more Jamie good morning good
morning Dana Seth Rogen's known for
movies like knocked up and the 40 year
old virgin but less well known the
star-studded comedy variety fundraiser
he and his wife created this year
available on Netflix we met up with
Rogen and his wife Lauren Miller Rogen
to talk about it his career and even
that controversy involving North Korea
my cousin is like your biggest fan in
the world and I was wondering could you
just make a video real quick for him
where you say his name then say for 24
life and then do your stupid laugh fresh
updating of the classic variety show is
is that what y'all were going for with
it yeah we really want to make a show
where you don't know what's gonna happen
where it's completely kind of unexpected
from one moment to the next yeah I'm
dying out here Seth that's what's dude I
can tell you're bombing you know we put
a lot of thought into how to not make it
feel like some like uptight stuffy
charity event what it is is hilarity for
charity an annual live event that's
raised millions to fight Alzheimer's
disease a battle that's wonderful wife
Lauren it's a joint venture with his
wife whose mother Adele was diagnosed
with the disease at just 55 years old I
was 25 at the time and felt very alone
and
scared and didn't feel like I had anyone
to connect to who really understood what
I was going through and a few years into
it we decided along with some friends to
start this event doing this work has
given us hope the charity made it feel
like we were going from just watching
terrible things happen to actively
taking steps to try to stop those things
from happening family struggling the
cause brought Rogen to Washington DC
large different kind of confinement the
situation is so dire that it caused me a
lazy self-involved generally
self-medicated manchild to start an
entire charity organization what's your
ultimate goal with the charity what's
your hope for our ultimate goal with the
charity is to help people tomorrow by
funding great research that's going to
make great strides and treatments and
cures for the disease and to help people
today by providing them care there was
the one who came up to me on a trip and
she's like the only reason I'm on this
trip is because I have one of your
grants Rogen's story began in Vancouver
Canada where he started performing
stand-up comedy when he was just 13
years old it was around that time that
he met his writing partner Evan Goldberg
and the two started working on what
would eleven years later become the
movie super bad all right you look like
a future pedophile in this picture
number one number two it doesn't even
have a first name it just says McLovin
it's one name one name well who are you
seal how close was it to what eventually
got made shockingly similar in a lot of
ways a lot of the jokes
honestly that we wrote when we were 13
were in the finished movie and are some
of the funnier jokes in the movie you
know it was written from such like a
pure emotional place like we were living
in
based on him a party we went to one
night something that happened some
weekend something that happened at a
dance Rogen's big break in front of the
camera came when he himself was still in
high school
landing a role in Judd Apatow's 1999 TV
series freaks and geeks they continued
to work together as Rogen's film career
blossom the project's he's known for and
pushed the boundaries of Hollywood
standards are you a virgin yeah not
since I was 10
it all makes sense you're a virgin
you've had a lot of incredible
opportunities throughout your career
would you say super bad is the moment
that impacted your career the most
honestly probably knocked-up is the
thing that impacted my that when they
happen back to back [ __ ] alright bring
it back swing fetch my kids just
treating my kids like they're dogs
knocked up came out in the beginning of
the summer and then super bad came out
at the end of the summer and basically I
went into that summer just being you
know a guy who was really trying to make
it in Hollywood and I came out of it
being a guy who had started an
incredibly successful movie and written
an incredibly successful movie it
completely changed my career but nothing
got him more attention than when he took
on North Korea and its leader in 2014 in
the irreverent comedy the interview
about two tabloid journalists given the
assignment to kill North Korean dictator
Kim Jong you want us to assassinate the
leader of North Korea yes
North Korea was not amused and the movie
became something of an international
incident it triggered threats against
movie theaters it was pretty stressful
and there was a few things that were
upsetting about it the way Sony was
handling it was not good in my opinion
they want to pull the movie from
theaters I think before it was a correct
decision to do that they were not
bagging us up the film was also widely
seen as sparking the Sony hacking
scandal when the corporation's private
emails and other data were posted online
many blame North Korea Rogen isn't so
sure honestly if you asked me I don't
think North Korea X Oni I think it was
someone who hated the Sony Corporation
and I obviously think for Sony it's
probably a better story than North Korea
hacked them and someone who just hates
them hacked them the interview was
eventually released for home viewing
through streaming services looking back
do you regret having done the film no if
anything I regret how I was convinced to
talk about the film when it came out by
Sony who kind of tried to make us seem
as though we weren't trying to make a
controversial movie and that it wasn't
something that we intended to be
incendiary which is completely untrue we
knew exactly what we were doing
it was incredibly well researched
despite what happened it didn't keep the
comedian from making movies even with
Sony Pictures is there anything that
really really surprises you that it
actually got got done and was successful
that you've done sausage party I was
just trying to say Frank always crank
you yeah I'm Frank
anytime anything we do does well it's
not lost on me if there was like one
movie I could have chosen to have that
happen to its that one because we spent
like ten years making it which is way
too long to make a talking hot dog
that's what happened what is the proper
length of time more than six months so I
went 20 times longer than he should have
hilarity for charities on Netflix now I
should say it is a very adult but very
creative and Rogen's wife Lauren wrote
and directed a movie called like father
that will premiere on Netflix this
summer Wow
I love what he said he's amazed that
anything we do does but it's so
interesting to hear how stressed out he
was by North Korea you know you forget
when I was doing my research for this
and talking to him you forget about that
time when there were threats to people
going to see the film it was the new big
news every day and he was personally
getting a lot of threats you know and
that's what comedy does though you walk
that very fine line of going against
everything maybe you shouldn't be that's
right
all right Jamie thank you we appreciate
you